يتجه الامريكيون في الثامن من نوفمبر الى
صناديق الاقتراع للمشاركه في انتخابات
التجديد النصفي للكونغرس وسط مخاوف كبيره
وترقب في الولايات والمقاطعات الامريكيه
حول سير العمليه الانتخابيه ونزهتها
انها المره الاولى التي تاخذ هكذا مخاوف
حيزا كبيرا من المشهد الانتخابي فانقص
العاملين والتصويت عبر البريد وتهديدات
باستخدام العنف ابرز الاسباب التي ادت الى
القلق من امكانيه خطف الديمقراطيه
هتجوزك المدينه
حضرنا الندوه عدها افراد فاعلون من
المجتمع يحاولون التحضير من المخاطر التي
تهدد الديمقراطيه الامريكيه ويحاولون
توعيه الناخبين حول الادلاء باصواتهم
وضمان احتساب خياراتهم دون الخوف من
الغائها
تتعلق بكل ما يخص العداله الاجتماعيه
ونظرا الى اننا سنشهد الانتخابات النصفيه
نعتقد انها ستكون فرصه جيده لمراجعه اهم
القضايا وقسم كبير من بلدنا توقف عن
الايمان بموسوقيه وفعاليه الانتخابات وهذا
امر مقلق لنا
المخاوف كانت كبيره لدى سكان هنا في بيت
سبورت فلا يمكن ان ننسى الاتهامات التي
وجهها الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب في
الانتخابات الماضيه بشان عمليات التزوير
طالت النتائج وادت لفوز المرشح الديمقراطي
انذاك والرئيس الحالي
ان يتاكد من ان صوته وصل الى مكتب
المقاطعه وتم احتسابه واذا ما اختار
التصويت في مراكز الاقتراع فيمكن التاكد
ان صوته سيحتسب اما التصويت بشكل مباشر في
مراكز التصوير فهو الطريقه الاضمن النقاش
حول امكانيات
المقبله العقبات التي قد تعترض المسار
الديمقراطيه عديده تتم مراقبتها من قبل
خبراء وحقوقيين على امل ان تطمئن من نزاهه
الانتخابات